We are entering the wrapping stage.
I want you to keep in mind that
a promise is a try-catch wrapper around
code that will finish at
an unpredictable time.
Here, let me show you an example.
Promise is a constructor.
You can either store a promise as
a variable like I'm doing right here.
Or you can simply work on it
as soon as you create it.
Either way works just fine.
But you'll often see me
simply work on the promise
without storing it as a variable.
You pass a function to
the promise with two arguments.
Resolve and reject.
Resolve and reject are two callbacks
that you use to specify when
a promise has either fulfilled,
because something worked, or
rejected because something went wrong.
Let me show you what
this actually looks like.
In this example, I'm wrapping an image
tag loader in a promise because
I want to do some work after
the image loads on a page.
I'm using the image tag's onload
handler to specify success.
Onload calls resolve,
which queues up the function,
passed to then to execute after
this function finishes executing.
Note, the JavaScript engine does
not immediately stop executing
this function upon calling resolve.
In this case,
that's the last piece of work so
effectively it's the end of the function
however, that's not always the case.
Check the link in the instructor
notes to see what I mean.
Being able to called resolve and
reject is important.
This is what it gives you
the flexibility to explicitly say what
constitutes fulfillment and what
constitutes rejection for the promise.
When either resolve or reject has been
called, the promise has been settled,
and then at that point,
the next part of the chain.
Usually, a .then, or
it could be a .catch is then executed.
Back to the original example,
any value passed to resolve or
reject will be received as an argument
by this subsequent .then or .catch.
In the event that nothing
is passed to resolve or
reject as is the case here with
the reject, then it's totally fine.
The next link in the chain
simply receives undefined.
There's a third case and that is if
the value that's passed is a promise.
If so,
then the promise will execute first and
then whatever value it resolves to will
be passed to the next link in the chain.
Note that resolve and
reject have the same syntax.
Resolve leads to the next
then in the chain,
while reject leads to the next catch.
Incidentally, if there is a JavaScript
error somewhere in the body of
the promise, .catch will also
automatically get called.
And by the way,
there's a bit more to error handling and
you'll be learning about
it in the next lesson.
In the meantime, it is time for
you to write your first promise.